hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal wann
und willkommen zu einem neuen test video
hier aus polen den doppel heute testen
wir polnische süßigkeiten und freut sich
schon tierisch von der polnischen
süßigkeiten blieb und die werden wir
heute testen ich meine wir kennen ja
schon viele fehler habe ich aber schon
seit ewigkeiten seit der kinder nicht
mehr gegessen die wahrscheinlich meine
mutter schickt mir ab und zu polnischen
sie können die mama wenn du das hier sie
sagt ihr bildung schreibt jung auch ich
mag keine trauben in schokolade keiner
markt tauben in schokolade ist rosi was
hab ich gesagt traum wir sollen motori
also ich glaube in dieser box sind
klassiker ja ich gesagt legen der schal
sieht halt echt so nach polnischen
auszug aus der sieht so ein bisschen
hilfst du musst jetzt so ich mache jetzt
auch und du musst zur eingreifen ohne zu
gucken und das die erste sache raus
ziehen
das hat mich hart kämpfen
die hauptsache ich nicht machen aber
wissen ja andere möchte ich nicht weil
es eine ganze
den stopp
wenn du dich gut fühlst handelst du auch
gut
das ist wieder ein bisschen so wie die
ernte dieses er hier bericht hier bin
ich mensch hier kauf ich ein
die berechnungen ich habe mir ein
bisschen zu weich was ist es eigentlich
das stück scheiße ich glaube ich habe
aus dass die gibt es ist super das kennt
man ja nicht es gibt nichts
vergleichbares ende deutschland es ist
irgendwie weich aber auch nicht weichen
und auch schon hart jetzt hab ich muss
so ein loch machen und dann noch nicht
noch die gibt's doch das sind einfach
die polnischen wie sie da auch noch
genauso aus
das ist moderne das so sagt vorher nicht
so sind groupies hast so karamell zeug
ja die sehen genau und was ist falsch
weil ich weiß dass hat es ungefähr ich
verweise man das deutsche wort nicht
ohne zucker creme das ist wie klara
misurak restes kam es gibt ja in england
ist ja voll beliebt ja und man hat ja
auch falsch manchmal roboter ist schon
hast du schon groß zeigt alles nicht wie
das englische wort guck mal
ja und das ist so unglaublich sie nicht
solle es ist einfach zucker mit zucker
auf zucker mit zucker drin drin was aber
nicht
ja manchmal weiß man den einen rein und
erst dann so das ist physiker und jesus
mehr müssen wir so flüssig
ich kann ihn nicht ich weiß das ist bds
bald kann man wieder karten kaufen wo
ich habe die einzelnen events sesam
plättchen haben die türken das nicht
auch haben die sondern haben
die habe ich auch sauer lange kredite
jetzt schon gerne respekt die haben
eltern einen auch lieber gegeben als
irgendwas anders weil es sehr gefragt
sind weder text ist es erlaubt genau und
es einfach so caesar nicht herr oder
sind kleineren herbe note von der reeser
von der saison das sesam ist ja sehr
sondern man hat nicht das recht im ort
kommst dann aus polen
ich wurde gewonnen durch diese technik
ist ruhig aber eigentlich also ihren
geliebten kurz corp das halt glatz auf
deutsch kann es gar nicht geschubst
das ist wie in hamburg also wie ich
hamburgerin ist ja wenn wir den polnisch
reden kamogawa
und das kann bis zu dem zeitpunkt noch
nie eingefallen sich überhaupt gibt dass
die das auch haben genau wie texas ich
glaube die leute kennen das konzept von
snake bin ich dran du bist irgendwann
die sonne schien vergessen nächstes
produkt darf unsere bunte wundertüte
fashion beauty fashion flug online
vorschnell das ist sauer
ein witziger waschen waschen
es gibt ja sehr dass ich das schild sz
und es ist es mit einem strick draus
firma lösung das heißt man sagt ja immer
aber man sagte schemesch auch im
internet schreiben alle maschen
und ich habe auch niemanden gefunden das
schema wie kann echt nur bücher und
coole eltern ja genau das habe erkenne
diese lettern polnisch von vor 30 jahren
dass die aber geil aus glaube ich schon
das ist aber gar nicht so kaster cola
das hat halt in haribo cola geschmack
bildung ist das was außen ist aber nur
ein bisschen flüssiger für ja was damit
zu tun haben
das mag ich auch überhaupt nicht
noch nie aber ich finde es sehr schön
dass das ist auf jeden fall ein
polnischer klassiker taschenmesser heißt
vogel milch und allein von den namen hat
mich damals zum total verstört ja ich
dachte man dass es wo ich glaube die die
ziele eines kleinen schwächen die specht
und das zeughaus das sind die tasche im
netz kommt also totoblock nur ganz denn
schokolade rum und deshalb ticket die
frisch gesetzte hat einen twitter kanal
und hat einen tisch geht regelmäßig live
und er hat auch einen podcast zwei
tomate zusammen mit freddie alles
verlinke ich euch in der video
beschreibung dort ein wichtiger termin
gerade was ist das nächste produkt die
praline stand ki.ka stanke was hast du
einen geschmack ich habe die kiste ist
[Musik]
ich habe gerade so zeitgleich das ist
der slogan nicht mehr so oder so das
nächste punkt masken cnet.com neues
karlowski ich halten ganz auseinander
gesetzt und hobby zu machen so ein
bisschen tieres operationen
ich habe aber das gehört nicht mir meine
liebe und noch eine ernste lohne das und
jetzt zurück es sieht aber auch aus ich
habe da überhaupt in bottrop ist schon
sehen was wir wert
sie haben entschieden denn das aber
einladen notebook das zuerst ich habe
angst davor und glauben wird schnell
dafür ist drin aber ich will auch nicht
zuviel irgendwie weil langsam mit der
langen mit
das heißt warum riegel ziemlich aber
wirklich extrem lecker findet ab weiß
ist entwickelt sich auf der zunge und
entwickelt sich so eine neue kasse darf
ich ja ich wollte mal als teenager weil
ich mal abnehmen weil ich halt doch dann
habe ich ihn immer so einmal an
fahrzeugen gegessen hast ja also wenn
nicht mehr fragen würde was an deutschen
höchst kein wollten ausprobieren
bedienung wird auch so sieht jeder
nächstes produkt und arthur hat noch
tschechien
mein vater das ist kassels zurück ich
weiß bis heute nicht was ist eigentlich
so lieb areals ist auch wie viel
kalorien auf 100 gramm haben 518 ja hier
sieht man sehr hin
das ist so faserig ja so faserig jaja
und ist supersüß verfahren das so
ähnlich wie faserig trifft sich schon
sehr gut und weiß nicht was ist wie
gedacht haben
geschmackvoll jahr bin ich jetzt dran ja
langsam geschlecht nicht halt gemacht
[Musik]
du kannst handgemacht nicht das ist
außen ist richtig bonbon weißenberg
pralinen ein bonbon also können sie ihn
auch ganze nun stecken
das ist eine freie lieder in den baum
wochen haben
cjk
so bin ich ja er nutzt das stille nacht
heilige nacht gut ist auf jeden fall
haben wir hier auch polen opladen
opladener vielleicht sind sie auch
einfach nur ganz normale bleiben
deswegen zumal wir hatten aber dies sei
dazu meine oma schick meiner familie
jedes jahr zu weihnachten ja aber weißt
du warum also willst du die geschichte
erzählen warum das weil man in polen zu
weihnachten oblaten teilt vor dem essen
kann man betet die hat meine mutter
macht das immer so die wird man im team
mal nachladen und dann macht macht er
zimmer und dann nicht auch das ersten
teller es sich vorstellen naja diese
stiefel atheisten teller unterliegen
dann zum geplanten drauf und dann wenn
wir die familie sind und alles ist
bedeckt und es geht jetzt los
dann stehen alle auf nehmen sich
bestehen jetzt komplett stehen im sitzen
und dann hast du auch eins in der hand
und dann musst du jetzt das abreißen ich
bin ich wünsche dir dass keine videos
erfolgreich werden dieses jahr dass du
glücklich wirst oder auch beim sport und
dazu noch tolle gutscheine bei lidl
kriegste in einer l und er muss es
abreißen und dann es ist sondern sich
und dann kontern und dann und dann muss
das gleiche für mich und dann mussten
jetzt etwas wünschen
ich wünsche dir dass das kind seiner
schwester wirklich gesund ist und dass
du dieses jahr ein toller onkel
hast du viele schöne sachen mit dem baby
machen kannst und das muss nicht fallen
lässt
danke ich weiß die reihenfolge also ich
glaube also das ding ist ich kann das
hier nicht als es kann eigentlich nicht
hier das ist ein bonus jetzt weil es ja
keine süßigkeiten das war jetzt kommen
wir zum kongo stehen
du hast doch was vorbereitet nicht dass
sie wenn das jetzt als sie aufgenommen
wird
das wird aufgenommen doch es wird auf 7
als krone finale gibt es galaretta
einmal in tusche und pop genre also etwa
und woran dies ist den man einfach so
mit dieser packung an mischt mit heißem
wasser und dann ist hast du lange her
also schon okay schmecken nicht so viel
essen nicht so viel geschmack und weiß
nicht gute orange also es ist so aber es
ist auch sehr wenig also sehr und
intensiv hin intensiv mit sich so ich
glaube es nicht so ich finde es nicht so
toll das ist doch aber so cool wenn
gäste aus und dann machst du sogar
riesenspaß alle gerichte trafen bisschen
sahne
es ist ein spaß und ich es ist eine
nachmittags beschäftigung ist einfach so
dass das ist eben zum spielen nicht aber
wenn du spielst du mitspielen
das ist ein echtes spielen soll
die amerikaner haben das nicht gelernt
haben gelernt dass man mitte spielen
soll hast du musst ihn einstellen
[Applaus]
ja der große polen teilte gestern nicht
in die video beschreibung zu gucken denn
dafür linke ich alles von abdul twitter
tue ich ich hab noch youtube-kanal
nichts mehr kommt kann man gaming
gerufen was bald aber da sind geile
sachen drauf kauf videos auch kochen
rauf dann verliere ich alles mit coffee
dass die playlist rhein auch mensch
schreibt mal gerne in die kommentare was
wir noch polnisches testen sollen weil
ich habe auf jeden fall das mit 8 und
noch mehr über polen zu reden tut es
halt nicht so angenehm fahrzeugen kam
hier ist so dass du dein abonnierbar
videos noch ein schönes video sulkovsky
clip mal drauf das ist die and car
solchen kommentar ich frau nennt cut
oder du brauchst ein system wie du warst
du machst bei der in car system in
meinem leben